Black Clover is absolutely insane right
now the latest reveals in the manga are
almost too crazy to believe but here we
are the final villain Lucius is about to
obtain unfathomable power he is about to
become a literal god with the power to
control create or destroy anyone he
wants if Asta wants to defeat Lucius and
save sister Lily along with the rest of
the world he will have to abandon his
humanity and become a dark God himself
the final battle in Black Clover is
almost here and it will be a clash of
gods a clash that could either destroy
or save the entire world so let's get
into it you guys know how this works if
you enjoy our Black Clover videos and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now it
only takes you a second but it helps us
with that YouTube algorithm and if
you're one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos but are not subscribed
yet do me a big favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing on YouTube is
completely free but it makes a real
difference finally this video will
contain Black Clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned so we all know that asta's
focus in this current Arc has been on
training his anti-magic zetted and that
is exactly what he was doing as sister
Lily and the other paladins invaded Hino
country the paladins resurrected the
legendary five-headed dragon and then
they started wrecking havoc in Hino
since Asta was still busy training at
least first and since he wasn't yet
ready to use his zetan members of the
ReUse and seven attempted to stop the
paladins they fought fiercely and
bravely and they bought astop valuable
training time but after some serious
fighting and after ichika learned the
dark truth about her father and her
repressed memories most of the ReUse and
looked like they were on their last leg
the paladins and that gigantic Dragon
looked like they had a clear Advantage
but before ichika and the others could
be seriously hurt Asta stepped in to
protect ichika our boy's training was
finally complete and he was now ready to
face the paladins including his beloved
sister Lily Asta used his newly acquired
anti-magic zetan as the ultimate
counter-attack against that Refugee
looking Paladin whose name is irule with
those Newfound Powers Austin managed to
take him out quickly and efficiently
which surprised everyone including Lily
and he yosuga of the ReUse and seven
then faced off against Heath while Asta
was forced to confront sister Lily this
entire time Asta has believed that
despite lucius's control over her sister
Lily doesn't actually want to hurt him
and that is why she transported him to
Hino instead of just killing him when
she had the chance
now Lily denies that she is being
controlled and she reiterates that Asta
has to die for the greater good she then
assaults him with both water magic and
spatial magic but as the fight
progresses Lily remembers Asta as a
child and she hesitates eventually she
admits that she doesn't really want to
kill Asta but she feels compelled to
kill him because Lucius has convinced
her that killing Asta is the only way to
achieve happiness and World Peace
clearly sister Lily is still herself on
the inside but she is simply being
temporarily manipulated by Lucius Austin
recognizes this and he knows that if he
plays his cards right he may be able to
use anti-magic to negate the effects of
lucius's control and bring the real Lily
back and so Asta slashes through Lily's
body with anti-magic but not with the
intent to kill her or even injure her
rather he wants free her from the
effects of lucius's Magic by purging his
magic from her body using anti-magic as
asta's anti-magic collides with sister
Lily she collapses out of the sky but
thankfully Asta is there to grab her and
place her gently on the ground a tearful
Lily apologizes to Asta for saying such
horrible things about him and she is
full of regret for all the other
terrible things that she's done under
the influence of Lucius it's clear that
Asta did succeed in bringing the old
sister Lily back but there's a catch she
is now extremely weak and barely able to
talk Lily explains that she became a nun
because she couldn't take the pointless
discrimination and classism of the
Nobles and so she wanted to do her part
to promote peace and equality by
dedicating herself to God and to helping
the less fortunate but she soon realized
that even within the church
discrimination and classism were more
rampant so she decided to abandon the
noble realm and head into the Forsaken
realm where she could work directly with
those who were less fortunate and being
discriminated against and now after
everything she's been through sister
Lily feels like she betrayed what she
stands for because Lucius manipulated
her into doing terrible things things
that she never would have done if she
was in control of her own body and mind
Austin Ryu assure Lily that this is not
her fault and that thanks to Asta and
anti-magic she will be saved along with
everyone else but sister Lily has a dire
warning for Asta she tells him that
Lucius is already preparing for the
final battle inside the Clover Kingdom
and actually there are only three days
left until his so-called Judgment Day as
many of us predicted long ago Lucius is
planning to combine the magic of the
sagratic siblings body Blood and Bone
magic together with his own soul magic
in order to gain access to unfathomable
power with all four of these magic
powers combined he will be able to alter
people's minds and bodies at will and he
will even be able to create people from
nothing like an actual God
then when his Judgment day arrives he
plans to take control of all the magic
in the entire world and become a truly
omnipotent horse the most powerful being
in the history of the world that is
absolutely insane when you think about
it imagine the ability to alter and even
create human minds and bodies like an
actual Creator God for those of you
familiar with Fullmetal Alchemist this
reminds me of someone who is able to use
a philosopher's stone someone who is
able to use alchemy freely without
regard for Equivalent Exchange I
absolutely love Fullmetal Alchemist
Brotherhood it's one of my favorite
stories of all time so I would love to
see the final battle against Lucius in
Black Clover achieve something similar
to the final battle against father in
Fullmetal Alchemist honestly this setup
for the final battle has a ton of
potential with these massive reveals
about lucius's godly power the stakes
are incredible probably high and it goes
without saying that the fate of the
entire world is on the line what an
incredible final battle this is going to
be Lily apologizes again for all her
actions and with tears flowing down her
face she reveals just how ashamed she is
that Lucius was able to control her in
this way but Asta refuses to let sister
Lily take the blame for this he tells
her that this is not her fault and he
vows to make Lucius pay for what he's
done with a fierce intensity in his eyes
Asta swears that he will defeat Lucius
sister Lily then loses Consciousness and
that you explained that although she
isn't dead she won't be able to open her
eyes again until Lucius is defeated
clearly there are some serious after
effects of lucius's possession that are
still impacting Lily and because of
those After Effects she will not be able
to fully recover until he is defeated as
fumito uses recovery yojutsu on Lily
Asta tells her to wait for him he will
defeat Lucius and set things right again
and he will then come back for her when
all is said and done but first things
first Asta declares that before he does
anything else he will slay the massive
five-headed dragon himself and as the
gigantic Dragon moves towards Asta the
chapter comes to an end this is big not
only do we have a three-day time limit
before Asta has to return to the Clover
Kingdom and defeat Lucius but we also
now know that asta's anti-magic zetan
can be extremely effective against
lucius's Power on top of that we know
that the final battle will be a clash of
gods because Lucius is about to attain
outright godly power and in order for
Asta to actually defeat him he will have
to bring his own anti-magic powers to
the level of a dark God as exciting as
all this is it doesn't make me wonder
will Asta have to renounce part of his
own Humanity in order to defeat Lucius
in the end will he have to make a deal
with the devil let's say asteroth in
order to take his powers to the next
level or will he maybe be forced to
unleash so much anti-magic that he can
no longer control it and he goes berserk
we all know how Shonen works and how
stories work in general with insane
Godly Powers there are always
consequences and if Asta is going to
become strong enough to defeat an actual
God he will need to make some sacrifices
we know that Asta is not the type of
person who would ever sacrifice someone
else so could he sacrifice himself could
he sacrifice his own soul in order to
gain enough power to defeat Lucius could
asta's Soul become corrupted as a result
of some sort of deal with a devil as we
get closer and closer to the end I keep
thinking about the fact that one of the
strongest devils in the world the Thai
magic devil asteroth just went missing
from the underworld and to this day he
hasn't been introduced in the series
there is certainly a good reason for
this and Tabata is definitely cooking
something big in relation to astoroth
honestly I can't wait to see what Tabata
has planned for asteroth oh and also
asta's dad because that's another
mystery that is yet to be revealed what
do you guys think who is Austin's dad
and is he related to asteroth we lost
become some sort of dark anti-magic God
in order to defeat Lucius will he have
to sacrifice some part of his Humanity
like for example his very soul in order
to gain enough power to triumph over
Lucius don't forget to leave your
feedback down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this Black Clover video and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now it
only takes you a second but it helps me
out a lot and if you are one of the over
50 of people who watch our videos but
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me me a big favor and make this the
moment that you subscribe with the way
YouTube works even if you watch our
videos regularly you're still not going
to be notified of every video unless
you're subscribed and you hit the bell
and you select that option that says all
it's definitely annoying but it's just
how YouTube works if you're looking for
a video to watch next don't ignore this
video right here on the screen as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys